I'm hoping we can talk about a character
with a goal and a character with no goal
and how would I be able to see that my
screenplay has like a character with a
week goal Oh interesting well so I think
most movies that you watch most
mainstream movies that you watch are
really built around a character pursuing
something right so I would say they all
they all have pretty definable goals um
any movie that you'll see that's like in
the theater I take that back not any
movie that you see most movies that
you'll see they're they're designed
around somebody who wants something very
badly and goes after it right so I would
say if you're trying to figure out
whether your character has a weak goal
probably the places that I would start
would be at your break into two this is
assuming you've already written the
script right at your break into two do
we know what your character is going to
be pursuing over the rest of the movie
that is that's their goal that's you
might not always think of it as a goal
it might be you might think of it as
just a conflict like this character in
this character are competing for the
same prize or something like that
you could look at it that way but we
know what we're tracking over that
entire movie right so I would say
establishing that goal is one part of
the question that you're asking and then
the other question the other part is
whether they're pursuing that goal right
and we want them to be pursuing it
consistently and against great odds and
opposition right throughout the entire
movies and so that is something that
you'd have to evaluate is my character
in virtually every scene it are they
pursuing that goal that big picture
thing that they're trying to accomplish
and if they are are they also running
into you know some form of antagonism
that's keeping them from making progress
too quickly or achieving that goal right
away without anything standing in their
way because we want both of those things
we want a strong goal but we also want
your character to pursue it actively and
have to really try to get it right so
with with bridesmaids if we go back to
that movie
an example if we look at her her goals
is the goal to win the friendship of the
one friend or to show up the other woman
well so the goal in that movie is for
her to be her best friend's maid of
honor right and the message remember we
talked about the method that she's going
to use is by competing with Helen right
so so she won't always have to compete
with Helen in order to achieve that goal
but that's that's her main force of
antagonism so she really is gonna have
to compete with Helen most of the time
and then I would say what's at stake in
that movie is her friendship among other
things but if we're you know we're just
sort of laying out the the sort of
building blocks of the set up that's how
I would kind of delineate them does that
make sense it does and so if I'm writing
a script and someone's not clear on like
why my character is doing certain things
does that maybe indicate that the goal
the hero's goal is not very clear well
if we know what they're trying to do
then I would say the goal is clear but
if we're not sure why they're doing
something I would say either there's
just a sort of a you know a plot logic
problem like we don't understand why
they think this thing is what they need
to do or it could also be a stakes
problem so we don't understand why we
don't understand why they're taking on
this goal in the first place because we
don't understand what it means to them
or what will happen if they don't take
it on or what happens if they fail you
know all of those things we need to
really understand sort of the motivation
behind your characters actions and a lot
of times that has to do with stakes
you